let's do another stoichiometry problem
where the reaction is occurring inside
of a solution so we have a metallic zinc
and it reacts with aqueous hydrochloric
acid we see that right there the
metallic zinc and then the hydrochloric
acid it is it is dissolved in water it's
an aqueous solution the solvent is water
makes these products right there and
they say what volume of 2.5 molar so
they're giving us the concentration of
the solution what volume of 2.5 molar
hydrochloric acid in milliliters so
we've got to remember that they want
their answer in milliliters is required
to convert 11.8 grams of zinc
completely to products so the way we can
do this we'll figure out we know we're
starting off with 11.8 grams right there
and we just have to figure out well if
we have 11.8 grams of zinc how many
moles of zinc that is and then assuming
this is a balanced equation and i'm
going to verify that right after i
finish this sentence but assuming that
this is a balanced equation for every
mole of zinc we're going to need two
moles of hydrochloric acid and then we
can figure out well given how many moles
of hydrochloric acid we need then how
much of the solution do we need based on
its concentration so let's do that it's
going to i think be a lot simpler when
we actually do it but i just want to
kind of give you the action plan before
we break into it but before we do
anything let's verify that this is
really a balanced equation so you have
one zinc on the left hand side one zinc
on the right hand side
two hydrogens on the left two hydrogens
on the right two chlorines on the left
two chlorines on the right so it looks
balanced let's do the problem so the
first thing we want to do we're starting
off with
11.8 let me do this we're starting off
with 11.8 grams
of zinc
grams of zinc they give us that
information now we're going to figure
out how many moles of zinc that is
so times we're going to want to convert
this to moles so it's going to be
moles
of zinc
over
grams of zinc moles per gram and if you
look it up on a periodic table zinc has
an atomic weight of
65.38 so its molar mass is
65.38 so it's one mole
for every
65.38 grams or it's 1 65th roughly of a
mole per gram
and this gives us
this gives us actually you know i'm just
going to keep all the math i'm going to
save our calculator for the end so this
the
grams of zinc cancels out with the grams
of zinc and we're left with 11.8
11.8 divided by
65.8
moles of zinc
moles of zinc
now we're trying to figure out how much
of this solution of hydrochloric acid is
required so the next thing we want to
figure out is how much how many moles of
hydrochloric acid are required
and we see that for every mole of zinc
we need two moles of the hydrochloric
acid so for every
let me write it this way for every
one
mole
of zinc put that in the denominator we
need and i'll switch colors just
arbitrarily here we need two moles
of hydrochloric acid that is
required and so then we can multiply the
moles of zinc
the moles of zinc will cancel out the
moles of zinc that's why i wrote 2 over
1 instead of 1 over 2 2 moles of
hydrochloric acid for every mole of zinc
and what does this give us this gives us
and i'm not going to do the math it's
11.8 times 2
11.8 times 2
over
65.38
and then we're left with moles of
hydrochloric acid required
moles of hydrochloric
acid hcl
required so we haven't solved the
problem yet we want to figure out how
much how many how many what volume of
the solution we need we know the actual
number of molecules we need but we need
to know how many how much solution will
contain that number of molecules
so we want to express this in liters
we'll eventually get to milliliters but
let's just go straight to liters first
because molarity is always expressed in
liters so let's multiply this we want we
want the moles of hcl to cancel out so
let's put that in the denominator
moles
of
hydrochloric acid and we and we want
liters of hydrochloric acid
liters
let me put it this way liters of 2.50
molar hydrochloric acid solution when
anyone puts this big m there that's
molarity you assume they're talking
about a solution because they're giving
you the concentration of the solute in
the total solution
so how many moles are there per liter
well this concentration is telling us
molarity is moles per liter so there are
2.50
moles
for every 1 liter of our solution that's
what that tells us this is a 2.5 molar
solution its molarity is 2.5 there are
2.5 moles for every liter and i wrote
the moles in the denominator because i
wanted to cancel out here so it's 1 over
2.5 so let's cancel those two guys out
that cancels out with
that right there
and then we are left with
we are left with 11.8 times 2 in the
numerator
11.8 times 2 in the numerator and in the
denominator we have 65.38
65.38 times 2. let me write the times
not as a
i'll write it that way times 2.50
and all we're left with in the
in our units is
liters of 2.50
molar hcl solution and then that green
required
required we're almost done we're almost
done we can get break out the calculator
get up the exact answer they want the
answer in milliliters so far we have the
answer in liters i mean there's going to
be some number here i don't know what it
is but it's that number liters of the
2.5 molar hydrochloric acid solution is
required let's convert it to so let me
just copy and paste this
let's convert this to
milliliters
because that's what they want
that's what they want so that's what we
had from the previous line and to
convert this to milliliters we've done
this drill before
we want the liters to cancel out
so we want the liters to cancel out i'll
just do it like this
so we want the liters to cancel out and
we want our answer in milliliters
and how many milliliters are there per
liter well there are 1 000 milliliters
per
1
liter and all of these steps you know
i'm showing it to you i'm making the
dimensions cancel out but hopefully
they're making some intuitive sense as
well
that you know we divide by 2.5 at this
stage because we have
more than one mole per liter so however
many moles we require we're going to
have fewer liters required so we're
going to be dividing by a number that's
greater than one if that doesn't make
sense to you just stick to the units but
every one of these steps i really want
you to actually conceptualize the
numbers at well but let's go back to the
problem so we're converting it to
milliliters so our final solution we're
left with we have the liters
canceling out the liters and so we're
left with in the numerator 11.8 times
two times one thousand times one
thousand
over that's the thousand right there
sixty five point three eight
times two point five zero
and in the numerator we're left with
milliliters of 2.5 molar
hydrochloric acid
milliliters of
i'll just write i don't have to write of
milliliters of 2.50
molar hydrochloric acid i don't want
this 2.50 molar hcl to confuse you these
aren't numbers in the computation this
is kind of a label to say what type of
solution we could have just written you
know over here we could have just
written liters of
the solution in question in case these
numbers confuse you we could have
written liters of
the solution liters of the solution and
then this would be
milliliters of
the solution i don't want that 2.5 to
confuse you that's just kind of the name
of the solution or how what is
concentration that's how we're
identifying it but now we've solved the
problem we just need to calculate this
number so let's break out
the calculator
break out the calculator and you get
11.8
times 2
times 1000 divided by 65.38
and we're also going to divide by 2.5
it's in the denominator it's
144. actually our lowest you see a
couple of numbers here only have three
significant digits so we should really
only stick to three significant digits
so it's 144
milliliters
so this right here
is 144 milliliters of we could say the
solution or of the 2.5 molar
hydrochloric acid solution and we're
done hopefully you found that fun